Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Conner's again, and I love looking at testing. Now, there's lots of different testing that a person can do, but when we're looking at toxicity, we really have to get some to some functional medicine testing.
That's typically not going to be blood tests. The ones that I'm going to talk about in this presentation are all urine tests, and then one of them is a hair analysis test.
The nice thing about these is that you can order these kits, get them in your home, do them in the comfort of your home, just follow the simple instructions, and then send them into the lab, we get the results, and we get you the results back to you with a very nice little action steps that I put together for you.
These are called functional tests. Now, I talk a lot in all of our courses about looking at genetics. This is a genetic profile, a metabolic profile that we look at with genetics. That's so important, too.
But besides your genetics, it's the epigenetics things that's going on. It's the exposure to mold and toxins and poisons and lime pathogens and other things that happen in our environment that often you can't even get away from that cause us to be sick.
So I put together this nice little package of toxicity testing that I was dealing with something like this is what I would want to do.
So we have to look at mycotoxin. So the first kit in this little package that I put together is the mycotox profile.
Now, all these kits are from Great Plains Laboratory, which I really love. Great Plains Laboratory. They're really highly rated in the functional medicine perspective.
These are great kits to be running. The mycotox profile is probably the best profile for mold and mycotoxins that is out there. It's a great little urine test to run and it gives us wonderful data.
The second one is the glyphosate test. Why would we test for glyphosates? Oh my gosh, I don't care how many years you've been eating 100% organic. You are still exposed to glyphosates.
And I tell you, I think this is the number one cause of cancer in our society right now is glyphosates and other pesticides and herbicides. But this is right up there.
Getting this tested is so important and then there's some measures that you can take. Besides just changing the way you eat, there's measures that you can take to help you with this if this is positive.
And then the third test is the GPL Tox profile. These are the non-metal chemicals that we're exposed to from painting products to chemicals in our home to chemicals in our environment to, we just can't get away.
We live in a world that we are poisoned on a daily basis. It's a good idea to measure those. Maybe there's one major thing that is home my goodness, this is off the charts for you and this is what we need to mainly deal with.
And then the last one of this profile is a nice simple hair analysis test for heavy metals. A lot of people maybe you've done this in the past. It's good to get this redone to see where it's at.
And really giving analysis of what to do to help pull out those toxicities. Now I told you I put this in a bundle. We call it our toxin testing lab bundle. You get all four of these tests. You can get them individually too on our store. You can just buy these individually.
We send you out the kit and each one of them comes with one of my action steps. But if you get it in the bundle, you basically get the heavy metal test for free. It's $150 savings. So it's really worth it.
And with that, we send you the results. We wait till all the results come in. And then we send you the results. Usually takes about two, three weeks. And then we send you the results. And it comes also with my action steps.
It's different things to do that I would recommend to follow. So we give you the action steps results as well. Hope you like it.